[Musica]
io sono siciliano è lo sono almeno da
cinque generazioni
eppure quando mi chiedo ma dove vengo in
qualsiasi parte del mondo mi trovo la
reazione della mia risposta è sempre la
stessa
oh my god i thought of salem non pare si
svegliano chiaramente molto non può
essere siciliano diciamo ma se ne scalo
ma una risposta che va in automatico e
dico sempre va bene voi non siete mai
stati in sicilia perché se nati in
sicilia di inoltrare nella folla
siciliana non solo noterebbe persone di
anghiò gli occhi azzurri come posso
essere io ma noterete battuta questa
varietà nei lineamenti somatici che poi
caratterizza quella che la nostra
bellissima isola
quindi la domanda vera è chi sono i
siciliani a un po greci arabi siamo un
po normanna
ora vorrei fare un gioco con voi del
pubblico
vorrei chiedere alle persone con i
capelli chiari gli occhi chiari di
alzare la mano bene voi siete sicuri di
essere al cento per cento siciliani
perché diciamo il vostro genere
principale nei paesi nordici quindi
qualche antenato norma non ci avrei
dovuto chiedere la stessa cosa alle
persone con i capelli scuri e gli occhi
scuri
vedo che qui arrabbiano dominante andrea
risol chi l'aveva book anche voi
ora vedremo persone con gli occhi chiari
ma i capelli scuri o carnagione scura
beh diciamo che qua il vostro genere sia
un po confuso perché la vedo un po
entrambi però diciamo che va bene anche
questi scherzi a parte
qui siamo a catania ecco questo volevo
solamente dimostrarvi che è la sicilia è
stata e continua ad essere un crocevia
di mondi e di culture di cui si sono
incontrate e noi siamo il risultato di
questo dialogo ed ettore al dialogo che
io mi sono ispirato per fare un progetto
artistico
io sono un fotografo vive all'estero da
parecchi anni durante una delle mie dei
miei soggiorni qui in sicilia venga a
conoscenza di un centro di accoglienza
per persone richiedenti asilo politico
in un paesino non lontano dal mio che
sia mirabella imbaccari un paesino di 5
mila abitanti nel sud est della sicilia
il centro una particolarità ovvero
quello di ospitare solamente persone
appunto richiedenti asilo politico ma
che sono solamente donne e bambini così
un po rattristito da quelle che sono i
commenti sul tema dell'immigrazione
commenti che stanno invadendo un po il
nostro paese ho sentito un po il dovere
di creare qualcosa che potesse dare un
volto nuovo e positivo rispetto a questa
a questa tematica
quindi io non sono un avvocato non sono
un politico quindi non posso figli
quello che è il tanto desiderato
permesso di soggiorno però posso
utilizzare mio strumento quello che
conosco meglio ovvero la fotografia
decido di andare al centro di conoscere
queste ragazze personalmente e
soprattutto di conoscere loro storia
storie molto importanti tutte quante da
chi ha lasciato il suo paese con uno
zaino in spalla alla ricerca di una
nuova vita
chi invece scappata da violenze e
torture
e lì che ho pensato di creare un
progetto che private sedare la loro
identità culturale ma soprattutto
utilizzando linguaggio estetico che a
loro diverte molto
ovvero il trucco e l'acconciatura dei
capelli
dovete sapere che nell'africa
occidentale soprattutto in nigeria il
trucco e capelli vengono usati per
esprimermi e delle emozioni
per avvenimenti importanti come possono
essere ad esempio matrimoni o funerali o
addirittura eventi di scala nazionale
come per esempio l'indipendenza
nigeriana all
l'impero britannico nato il mito degli
anni sessanta punto le donne di lagos
hanno inventato un look che si chiama
talk house italiana sarebbe una casa
alta che è diventato raccontano
alimentato questo questa acconciatura
per dimostrare la loro felicità per
appunto essere finalmente i dipendenti
dal regno unito un look che è diventato
un vero e proprio simbolo
dell'indipendenza nigeriana ecco
ispirato da storie come queste io ho
deciso di chiedere alle persone di
mirabella alle ragazze di mirabella di
esprimere la loro emozione di essere
appunto una immigrata è i richiedenti
asilo politico in questo particolare
momento della loro vita che è un momento
unico
così ho chiesto loro di essere belle e
di raccontarlo punto la loro storia
attraverso il trucco e capelli ed è nato
così il progetto mirabella racconti di
bellezza un progetto che è un progetto
di ritratti di 15 di dati più o meno di
cui ora vorrei condividere con voi un po
della loro storia lei è
lei e lo slot una donna ghanese non è
persona amabile una mamma era una
persona amata da tutte le ragazze del
centro cucinava per tutti e racconto la
alla mamma del centro era però molto
aveva una grandissima nostalgia del suo
paese
quindi abbiamo era un po triste vita
quindi quando abbiamo creato questo look
lei ha avuto dedicare appunto questa
questo progetto suo paese che appunto
chiamato sia la foto che nella sua
lingua significa madrepatria ghana lei è
suite con una ragazza divertentissima
era sempre voleva essere sempre al
centro dell'attenzione è una
chiacchierone incredibile e anche lei
molto simpatica e soprattutto aveva
sempre questa cuffietta addosso che non
si poteva far togliere quando abbiamo
fatto là quando l'ha fotografata ho
deciso di avere appunto questa forchetta
perché era impossibile sentiva sempre a
mosca e quindi ho deciso bianche poi
sembra a parte la pubblicità dell'iphone
comunque sembra molto divertente lei era
appunto la regina del campo quindi
quando mi ha chiesto quando abbiamo
pensato nel suo look voleva appunto
crearsi la sua corona ha mandati in
posti che conoscevano loro qui a catania
poi sconosceva completamente dove
abbiamo trovato un po di attrezzature
che possiamo utilizzare fin quando hanno
trovato questa collana di disegni
africani che abbiamo appunto utilizzato
che hanno appunto utilizzato come la
loro corona la sua però lei e josephine
già sentiamo anche lei una ragazza
nigeriana anche lei molto simpatica
abbiamo passato giornata intera a
chiacchierare faceva l'attrice quindi a
dare personalità fantastica ma
soprattutto la fila che mi faceva sempre
ridere che avevano accento impossibile
con cui riusciva a capire niente di
quello che diceva però avevamo un nostro
modo di comunicare perché le parlava
questo bug english le stesse mi diceva
che parlava il bambino oppure
formalmente si chiama
il bari invece dovete sapere che è un
dialetto che è stato sviluppato durante
la schiavitù il periodo della saga di
due nigeria per non farsi riconoscere
sì capire da quelli che erano i
colonizzatori ed è un po come il nostro
dialetto siciliano lei e p quando l'ho
conosciuto al centro era non veniva mai
a parlare con le altre ragazze sarà
sempre un po in disparte
ero molto colpito dalla sua bellezza di
uno sguardo bellissimo però anche un po
stand infatti questa cosa mi dava un po
di te stesso non riusciva a capire
perché da sempre un po atteggiamento un
po perso nel vuoto
poi mi sono informato ho capito che era
sotto psicofarmaci e quindi è una
persona molto molto sensibile a poco a
poco col tempo sono riuscito a trovare
un punto un punto di dialogo e aveva
questi capelli che mi ha raccontato che
appena arrivata in sicilia appunto per
tagliare con il passato avuto tagliarsi
aveva dei capelli molto lunghi e da
questi a decine molto lunghe
però per tagliare con il passato voluto
taglia tagliarsi al è appena arrivata in
sicilia è però non ha fatto molto bene
quindi avere un po questi capelli
brizzolati non proprio belle quindi
quando siamo riusciti a fare questo
progetto lei mi ha chiesto di riavere
nelle sue treccine è stata molto felice
di accontentarlo
qua abbiamo invece quindi anche le
nigeriane lei l'artefice di tutti 80 per
cento dei capelli che sono state fatte
le ragazze di mirabella perché anche le
stesse era una parrucchiera lei veniva
era il suo lavoro che faceva il suo
paese e quando le ho proposto appunto
questo progetto era super felice perché
finalmente ha potuto dimostrare al mondo
quello che era capace di fare quindi
anche una lavoratrice incredibile perché
dovete pensare che queste acconciature
impiegano ore ore per realizzarla e lea
ne ha fatte parecchie quindi ha lavorato
notte e giorno per realizzare questo
progetto
fate grazie a lei anche che sono usciti
a ottenere quello che abbiamo fatto
lei si chiama blessing lessing quando
l'ho conosciuto anche lei mi ha
raccontato che si è tagliato i capelli
quando è arrivata in sicilia anche lei
per appunto tagliare col passato
quindi quando gli ho chiesto come voleva
essere fotografata lei ha proprio scelto
di essere fotografata così perché la sua
il suo modo di esprimere la sua nuova
vita e con il carrello appunto sbagliato
così corto a questa forza di
ricominciare da capo
anche lei si chiama blessing un'altra
blessing devo sapere che questi sono i
nomi che comunque loro si danno il loro
destino mi non sono questi però anche le
6 m bless blessing ha una storia
importante perché quando l'ho
fotografata era incinta di quattro mesi
dopo un paio di mesi sono tornate al
centro perché come faccio sempre nei
miei lavori prometto sempre una stampa
alle persone che fotografo è un modo per
ringraziare del loro congiunto
quindi è tornato nel centro rincontrato
blessing
purtroppo venga a scoprire che ha perso
il bambino una notizia che un po mera
vestito parecchio
questa foto è importante per me anche
perché ha voluto attraverso questo luca
ha voluto ringraziare il paese di
mirabella perché appunto in questo paese
le ha trovato la sua nuova vita ha
trovato il suo nuovo lavoro è solo amore
è appunto questo look l'ha chiamato
mirabella questo progetto ha avuto
parecchie vite è stato pubblicato
parecchio in inghilterra negli stati
uniti anche qui in italia sono molto
felice perché i media hanno apprezzato
quello che ho fatto non sempre diciamo
vogliono condividere delle storie che
non rispecchiano la loro linea ma la
cosa più importante che sono riuscite a
fare con questo progetto è quella di
organizzare un evento
ho fatto anche parecchie mostre sempre
qui in sicilia è una di quelle che
voglio raccontarvi è stata realizzata al
parma di favara è un posto incredibile
che sta a favara è un centro culturale
dedicata appunto alle arti contemporanee
di cui avuto la fortuna di esibire il
mio lavoro
grazie all'organizzatore agli
organizzatori siamo riusciti a creare un
evento dove abbiamo invitato dai ragazzi
del centro di mirabella per appunto
iniziare un interazione col pubblico
dove loro hanno cucinato i loro piatti
tipici hanno danzato le loro danze
tradizionali ma anche ha fatto i capelli
alle bambine
questo è stato un evento che mi ha dato
due hanno capito anche il dolore perché
non sono delle acconciature che proprio
non indolori
questo evento mi ha dato anche lì molta
molta gioia perché sono riuscito
veramente a creare quello che volevo
fare con questo progetto ovvero iniziare
questo dialogo
di cui noi noi siamo parte e che non
dovremmo mai dimenticare
[Applauso]
[Musica]